hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trendsenses.com so in this video i would
like to make a huge update on gamestop i
would like to check
with you guys all the past price action
try to see if the elliott wave rules
applied well in the past
and what would be the outcome if they
apply well in the future
so let's get into it
[Music]
and yes in this video i will use elliot
with theory as usual
feed ratios extension and some trendline
and
divergences signals so let's start with
a step back
because it's important guys here to
remember
what is happening on the long run
because right now everybody feels like
are we
very bearish uh yes we are on the short
term
but look at the longer term guys all
right this is
the counting i'm showing you guys here
so basically
we having here the first move that
started in march
one two here we have this third wave one
two three four five that i'm gonna come
back to
you're gonna see i have some very
interesting things to show you guys
here that is actually showing that amc
case and gamestop case are
very different uh but i'm gonna keep
this for
later for now let's assume this third
wave is here
so then we have a force wave here guys
that is actually ongoing i think we are
we have not completed this correction
yet
and then we're gonna have a fifth so
i'm gonna give you my target for the
fifth wave as well for now
let's analyze this four slaves so it's
not easy guys uh to be honest i've been
struggling since
uh this morning to try to find the best
counting and i'm going to show you
what i came up with so for now i think
that we are in this triangle
so a b c d e it's not perfect let's be
honest the c wave i would have
liked to see a c wave deeper you know
something like this
that would be closer to you know
the theory but you know we had support
here we went higher
for now i'm going to keep it like this
even if it's not perfect
but assuming we are in this force wave
correction
and that we are in the e wave of this uh
force wave correction that would be a
triangle before the fifth wave
then here i'm gonna try to analyze with
you guys what is happening
in this force wave so sorry in this
e-wave of this false wave so
uh once again i'm gonna come back to
this
very often so those are my two very
important ratios that i'm gonna use the
ratio for the fifth wave
once you have one plus three it's
working for moves up or from moves down
uh basically saying that the fifth wave
is a ratios of one plus three
either 0.618 in this case you just
divide
this by this or 1.618 just divide
38.2 by 61.8 and
you're gonna see that those ratios
actually appear a lot
in any five wave development and another
ratio that i'm going to use
that is very useful as well once again
guys gamestop
and amc cases are unique this method
applies very well in any type of market
and for amc and gamestop you're gonna
see that it's not always working
perfectly for amc i should do yesterday
that
the ratios were very well respected but
we're going to see that for gamestop
it's another story
so for now here i'm going to come back
to this
false wave correction because what we're
interested in is to know is it
completely not
where are we heading here this is the
question we are having
so the first thing i'm going to try with
the w x
y correction so i measure the w wave
that is coming from here to here
i put it to the top of the y wave and i
check
the uh ratios so the different ratios
that we are having here
are simply the 0.618 for the c wave
of uh sorry for the y wave it can be one
two one or
one two open six one eight so here it's
giving me 136
or 80. okay let's just keep this numbers
in mind
let's dig a bit into this scenario so if
this is true then the y wave is an abc
itself
okay and let's check the ratios between
a and c okay
so now it's giving me once again if i
want
this ratios to be applied so one two one
or
one two 0.618 this is valid too even if
it's not
here it's happening a lot uh at least
it's what i'm seeing
so if we go to the one to one it's gonna
give us 123
all right which is quite close for the
137 that we had before
once again let me remind you guys here
that those
ratios they giving you areas right it's
not like a trend line
uh that is you know a precise support
where everybody is going to put their
orders
the fib areas are just you know it
really depends
you know you can see just the way i do
it you know there is a lot of
approximation okay if i do it here it's
137
if i just you know put it slightly
higher it's 134 so this is the reason
why this only gives you some areas and
this is what i'm trying
to you know show you guys in my discord
everywhere this is the reason why i
started this channel
is because i want to actually you know
show you what
is working and what is not what i use
and what i
don't use this is the purpose of me
making these videos and by the way let
me very quickly explain because a lot of
you asking me the questions
what is happening on my discord so very
quickly guys
i'm taking a big risk here i can tell
you because you know i quit my job
you know i'm going in in this project
and i decided to
show you the trades i'm gonna take guys
all right i think that no one else is
doing this
i'm now associated with another trainer
we're gonna do this together we're gonna
try to show you how to use
these techniques that i'm showing you to
make
money all right and we're gonna disclose
everything
we do and of course it's a big risk
because there is no guarantee we make
money
i'm very sure we will because this is
what we are
used to do but uh this is a risk i'm
taking and it's gonna start in september
so for those who interested just click
on the link in the description of this
video
and join the movement but let's go back
to gamestop case
i'm trying to you know use the different
ratios and see what
level is actually fitting the different
ratios that i'm trying to compute here
and i already see that 135 is a level
that is fitting both the relation
between the w and the y
wave and between the a and the c wave of
the y wave
so it's level that i have you know that
is important for me
and it's also here the support level
that we had it's not a level i came up
with today guys
and it's funny to see that the price
action is somehow
giving you different scenarios that go
to this level by using the android wave
rules
so this is the level we're going to keep
in mind now i want to show you an
alternative scenario
that is not a wxy but that is here
a big abc what's the difference is that
we're having
five three five five three five
instead of three three three so let's
try to apply
this scenario here so
my a wave is here one two three four
five
all right so if i zoom in here more i'm
gonna stay on the daily because it's
just
cleaner okay and i'm gonna try to see
what where the c wave might be going so
here
i'm gonna do the same thing one
two three four and five and i'm gonna
now that i have an impulse that is
subdividing my c wave i'm gonna try to
apply the ratios
to this wave and see where
it might be going so the first thing i
have here guys
is that once again the fifth wave i
remind you
is either 1.618 if it's extended or
0.618 of oneplus 3.
so in this case the 0.618 brings us to
153
level so this would mean in this
situation
that this correction is complete once
again we
had some access here as you can see we
went below but
like i said fib ratios are only areas
all right it's not precise so it's
totally fine to have some access
we can see that 150 253 has supported
the price
and that we are consolidating around
this level and i have something else
so let me go on first time frame have
something else for you guys here is that
as you can see on the forest time frame
we have the breakout of the 160 level
last week which actually created a new
low usually when you have a new low
with a breakout the bears should take
control and that should make a new
low on the macd which they didn't the
market bounced back here
so this is creating a bullish divergence
but once again
bullish divergences are very good to use
if you have
also the breakout of the shorter term
which would happen
here so this is what we're looking for
for this scenario to be valid
so once again i remind you the scenario
this scenario is saying that basically
um the fifth wave is going to the 0.618
so if this is true and we have the
bullish divergence so
it's likely that this is correct then we
should have a breakout
here all right of this bearish trend
line around the 160 level
so if the market trades above 160 during
this week it probably means that this
correction is over that the fifth wave
went here
and that we are completing the false
wave
now i need to show you an alternative
scenario that is looking quite bad
but this is going to show you a number
that you probably heard on the on
other youtube channels because i heard
that on my discord a lot of you were
discussing this
and i think that this is where this
number is coming from
is once again you apply this relation
and here you can see that the fifth wave
might as well go to the
1.618 ratio right if it's extended okay
so once again this is this situation so
if the fixed wave is extended
we would probably go towards this area
all right which is
really not looking good uh but don't
worry we have some levels below which we
know that probably we're gonna go there
and for now they're far from here
and let me just measure in this
situation what would be the relation
between
a wave and c wave sorry
okay it would be a one-to-one relation
so
this would also fit both this case and
extended fifths
so this ratio and this ratio
so this would be a valid counting that
is respecting ratios
for the larger degree wave counting and
for the subways as well
so i would be you know very careful
so let me tell you what i think might be
the trigger
as you just saw guys we have two
scenarios either 135 roughly
152 so 52 35
or 86 so if we basically break 135
then look at the longer term trend here
if i connect just the lows between here
and here this is showing you guys
uh what is the trend and the trend is
bullish but if we break 135 around the
18th of august
technical analysis often shows you some
levels
uh you know that are basically at the
intersection of different trend lines
and here i have one you know at 135 on
the 18th of august so basically if we
break this
this would be for me the signal that
we're going to 86 all right
but as long as we stay above 135 we have
two scenarios that are strong cases
that fit very well everything and that
showed that this correction is complete
if this correction is finally complete
what is the level we might be going to
once again this you know this number
guys i showed you this number many times
and once again this is only valid
in the hypothesis that this counting is
correct
so you know we're going to find out but
we it's going to bring us to the 800
area all right if we have a fifth wave
i'm using here this ratios so if you
have a fifth wave that is
1.618 times one plus three so extended
then it's going to bring us
to this area and the last thing i wanted
to show you guys
is that on amc like i showed you
yesterday
the ratios are very well respected in
each sub wave you know if you take any
wave and this is why i was a spot on
during the move of june it's because the
fibrations were very well respected
look at gamestop guys if i measure one
and three
here and then apply to the bottom of the
force just look
what it is this is a squeeze this is a
massive big squeeze
we went usually we go to the one point
six one eight
here we didn't go to so 37 and you can
see we had by the way
some reactions at 37 all right so don't
be surprised
okay those people who were sitting here
they were probably using this
method okay first thing but then it it
just
squeezed hard and it went not to double
not to
triple not four times but something much
higher
than this and it went to five of 400 nt
so this is a short squeeze and we didn't
have this on amc
yet so let's see if we have it but this
is just a small thing that i wanted to
show you
is that of course technical analysis is
helping us to build scenarios to try to
find what is fitting the best
but when things go wild when shots are
covering massively together
of course this can just go to the moon
and no one can predict the levels this
level was unpredictable so this was just
a small thing i wanted to show you
is that of course i will keep using
technical analysis
but we need to be very careful for this
unique uh case that our gamestop and
amc so i hope you guys enjoyed this
video i hope i managed to explain to you
what are the different
scenarios for me what are the different
levels to watch to know which scenario
we are
probably going to and if you did enjoy
this video please don't forget to click
on the sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything
new and stay close to shore i see you
guys